- You were speaking about
how you're recording
and all these beautiful
musicians y'all were getting
to get to make this music together.
And you have a new album,
"Great Songs from Stage and Screen."
I love your voice
because I, one of my favorite
singers is Rosemary Clooney.
I love that whole style of singing
and I love that it's happy music.
Was that on purpose?
To do something that was kind
of a little bit more happy
and not so melancholy?
- Yeah, well, you know,
we recorded most of this
prior to the pandemic
in London at Abbey road.
So it's--
- Oh my God!
- It's fortunate that it is
upbeat and not, you know,
'cause we do do a lot of sad
albums as well, so luckily
the timing of this worked out,
'cause I don't know that,
you know, more depression would be
what people want right now but...
Yeah, as it turns out, you
know, it's very upbeat.
It's every song is sort of a
pop version of a,
a song from a film or a Broadway show.
And yeah, it's just supposed
to be fun and upbeat and,
you know, just it's a bubbly record.
- I mean, it's a bubbly
record, but you're so gifted.
And I was just curious,
did you start like young singing?
- You know what, I
started with Kelly Okey.
(laughter)
- Well, that's why you're amazing Seth.
- Yeah, you know, I, you know, I was,
my parents always felt that music was a,
an important part of the
developmental process of the brain.
And, so they always
had music in the house.
You know, my father played the guitar.
My parents signed me up for a
a church choir, when I was a kid.
If you can believe that.
- I was, and that's hilarious
now your style of writing,
but I was actually a
church choir kid as well.
- Yeah, I'm sure,
you were, it fit a little better.
I was a little bit of a fish out of water.
I was not, I was not a...
I probably shouldn't have been there.
But, it was fun, I loved it it was great,
It was great fun and it was,
again, it was like it was really
helpful for developing
the voice and whatnot.
And so that,
you know, made its way into
local shows, local musicals.
My sister and I both really tried to stay,
you know, somewhere in that world,
even on just a local level.
- Yeah, it's fun.
Especially when you're a kid.
I did all that stuff too.
So is it true you trained as an adult
with the same teachers
who trained Sinatra?
Because you have a certain
flare that is Sinatra like,
that I love.
- Well, they,
it was an elderly couple.
They were at Lee and Sally Sweetland.
They were both in their late nineties.
And I trained with them
for at least 10 years.
Probably longer than that.
And they, yeah, I, you know
they had worked with Sinatra
at one point, I believe.
I know they trained
Streisand at one point.
I, I've never really done my homework
and gotten the full rundown of what their,
what their celebrity roster is, but
I've gotten fragments
and it's very impressive.